[Musique]
vendredi 16 décembre le parvient les
droits de loris tu es face au théâtre de
champ fleuri a été baptisé marvie des
droits de l'homme et de la laïcité par
le département
cette place pour prier de la
collectivité temps au lieu de
rassemblement riche en symboles de
recueillement de dialogue ou encore de
combat contre les injustices et les
inégalités la république allait elle a
trois valeurs essentielles la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité et aujourd'hui
la liberté de croire ou de ne pas croire
n'est pas contagieux mois dans l'esprit
des plus jeunes à qui est le principe
qui défend cette liberté de croire et de
ne pas croire c'est bien le principe de
la lèze et cette place du royaume
citoyens reflètent déjà la défense de
ses principes depuis longtemps mais ça
va être un moyen aussi d'aller plus loin
et de contribuer à l'affirmation de nos
valeurs qui cimente année surtout
particulièrement la réunion mais aussi
qui permettent d'affirmer notre présence
bien mais on sent une volonté d'affirmer
que la laïcité est indissociable de
valeurs de liberté d'égalité de
fraternité que tous ces idéaux sous
plantations le québec laval secteur est
en lien étroit avec la liberté c'est la
liberté de conscience est en lien étroit
avec légalité parce que c'est l'égalité
citoyenne et droits quelle que soit sa
religion et sa conviction est que la
laïcité doit vivre de manière
fraternelle
et ça c'est pas une règle qu'il peut
l'imposer c'est vraiment les acteurs de
la société civile qui peuplent le
passionné cet acte a été matérialisée
par une plaque oeuvres réalisées par
l'artiste xavier daniel intitulé
humanité une sculpture monumentale
formalisant la devise de la république à
laquelle est adjoint un quatrième mot
celui de la laïcité
[Musique]